[Music]
we got a great we have a great group
today and I'm a realtor real pleasure to
introduce today's speaker lottery one
Angelica I think is obviously a much
better role model to this old bike for a
lot of the prizes right so so so gum and
I are a westerner and Angelica is also
from the internet
blackjack dealer in Las Vegas and
there's a you know creeps around the
internet and she just scratch her
grandfather has having ramen noodle
irritations and that means you with the
different if anyone else is from the
West
you know that my
[Music]
[Music]
thank you thank you for that kind
introduction and thank you for allowing
me to share your your Saturday morning I
know it's hard to get up here especially
to get out of bed in this cold so I
really appreciate that you took the time
to come out here and hear a little bit
about what we do here at Yale and what
I've been doing for my whole life so the
theme of my talk is gonna be about
tissue engineering and how we use
biomaterials to solve some of our
problems and understand how our body
works in its healthiest state but also
understand how our body works during
disease progression and maybe how we can
develop some new tools to solve some of
those problems but I thought it might be
a good idea to tell you a little bit
more about who I am and where I come
from and so as a professor zome
indicated I grew up far far away from
Connecticut I grew up in Las Vegas
Nevada which is was at that point to me
on the other side of the world both you
know socioeconomically logistically and
and geographically far far away from
places like Yale and Harvard but somehow
through some kind of windy road I ended
up here at Yale as a professor so I'm
surprised by that still everyday that I
could I could be here so I wanted to
tell you that this although it didn't
seem like the direct path for my career
or how a person like me could end up
being a professor at Yale all of the
things that I learned along the way from
my parents my grandparents my kids now
and my students have all informed the
way I do science today and have made me
what people consider an innovative and
creative scientist to think about
attacking new problems in very new ways
so overall but I hope you get out of
this even if you don't remember any of
the science afterwards is that all the
influences that you have today and all
the experiences you have will make you a
better professional a better scientist a
better attorney a better author when you
get to that end state so yeah I grew up
in Las Vegas and this is what everybody
thinks Las Vegas looks like how many
I've been to Vegas yeah nobody under 21
should raise their hand right so yes Las
Vegas almost everybody should visit that
because it's one of the places where you
can see the Eiffel Tower the Egyptian
pyramids you can see Paris all on one
Street so it's an amazing place to visit
but what people don't realize is that
this oasis is in the middle of this
desert in the middle of a valley where
there's no water and so all of the water
that comes to Las Vegas right here in
the middle of this in this the middle of
the state is given to us we're provided
by irrigation specialists people who
provide and dig ditches and create
reservoirs and supplied the man-made
lakes to give us water and so what I
really thought was that in order for us
to have some of these lush fields in
Nevada that give us the food and provide
hay and alfalfa for our for our animals
we needed to think about how we could
get more efficient water delivery into
this desert and I watched my grandfather
so as professor zoom indicated he was
one of the people who ran these
facilities to to deliver water into the
fields and what I realized was that I am
not made to be in 110 degree weather in
the summer to deliver water outside I
like wearing nice shoes and I like being
inside in air conditioning so that was
not gonna work for me
so I thought I would go to a place like
Utah State University that would allow
me to learn how to do computational
irrigation system develop computational
irrigation systems and when I got there
that was a new idea and it was something
that I thought I understood irrigation
systems I can go in there and figure out
how to make it easier to get water to
these systems and all of this again was
informed because I was able to ride in
the back of the truck with my grandpa's
he was going from field to field to
irrigate when I got there what I saw was
there was not a lot of people who looked
like me doing irrigational engineering
but what happened in that experience was
that I realized that being the only
one who looks like me there wasn't a lot
of women in that that room there wasn't
a lot of minorities in that room but
being one of the only people who looked
like me in that environment made me
stand out and so my professors would
always know when I wasn't in class they
would always know when I was not doing
well so I became I was responsible for
both the successes and the failures that
I had in class and really had to make
sure that I did well so I was at Utah
State University I got a flyer in the
mail one day and that fire advertised a
summer program at Baylor College of
Medicine and that's in Houston Texas it
was a joint program between Baylor
College of Medicine and Rice University
that was introducing engineers to
biological sciences I knew nothing about
biology but I thought it's a summer in
Houston I don't have to be sweaty in
Vegas so I'll go and see see what
happens I applied to the program and I
got in and when I got in I went to hot
Houston hot humid Houston in the
summertime so the heat followed me I
feel but what this opportunity did was
it gave me an experience where I was
able to apply some of the fluid dynamics
and some of the water flow principles
that I learned to biological systems
because I didn't realize that the same
way that water flows through through
pipes and tubes and ditches is the same
way our blood flows through our veins so
I could apply some of those same
principles that I learned on the farm in
irrigational engineering to the study of
vascular disease and just in that summer
what I learned is that all of the babies
who are in Texas Children's Hospital
that I got to see all of the experiences
of working with humans in the hospital
really gave me motivation to think about
how I could have a different perspective
on developing new tools for biological
sciences and so I applied to Baylor
College of Medicine in rice program in
structural and computational biology and
molecular biophysics knowing not what
any of that meant and I got into the
program and stayed there for
four or five years to get a PhD and that
PhD led me to Yale it wasn't that I had
so much knowledge but now I was perfect
for Yale but the new tools and the new
way I was thinking about vascular
biology and attempts to develop new
tools for bioengineering was something
that was attractive at a place that was
that valued innovation and so that's why
I was hired here at Yale University in
the Malone Engineering Center that's
right down the street on Prospect so if
you drive by you probably see seen this
glass building and here I developed new
clinical technologies for neonatal
neonatal infants so preemie babies we
develop skin grafts for children who are
experienced burns or chemical injury and
we develop new vascular models for
infiltration and survival of tissue
engineered organs so all of that stuff
all of the basic principles of
engineering that I learned along the way
from my dad who was a mechanic for my
grandpa who was an irrigational and
irrigational scientist and even the math
that I learned for my mom she taught me
probabilities because she was a
blackjack dealer so I know when to want
to double down and went and went to
split all of that information that I got
it along the way is what led me to be
the kind of scientist I am today and so
what do I do today well what people
don't really know about professors and
scientists is that we have a lot of
roles one of my roles is to be a teacher
so I teach classes every almost every
day at the University and my job there I
feel is to introduce science to students
who want to apply science so I teach
them new ways to build tools and build
materials so that they can apply them in
the real world
my other job is to develop new science
and in my lab I it's like a small
company we develop these new tools and
we put them into animals we trial them
in humans and we get them out into the
world so that when we have an injury we
have a way to treat those injuries and
then my other job is being a mother
being a daughter a sister a friend and
olives all of that comes with that and I
call this my job because all of it
informs what I do in the end these are
my twin they're seven years old now so
they'd be embarrassed by this picture
but all of these experiences again have
created the devices and the research
that I do so it's the irrigation systems
that help us develop vascular systems
it's understanding the likelihood or
probabilities of cells might to move
that helps us understand cell migration
my interest and being able to observe
children both my own children and those
children in Texas Children's Hospital
that allowed me to develop these
neonatal respiratory devices and even
some of the terrible experiences my
grandfather died of of cancer have
motivated me to start thinking about
cancer therapies and understanding
cancer therapies for improved treatment
so again even though I would have never
expected to be here I'm here and the
only reason I'm here is because I had a
diversity of experience that gave me a
difference a different kind of mindset
in the way I approach my science and my
engineering so let me tell you about our
science and our engineering but I
encourage you to ask questions along the
way if you have questions about any of
that or any of the science please stop
me so we can clarify all right okay so
the goal of my lab and the goal of my
work is really to drive and use what we
have available to us which is tissue
engineering scaffolds biomaterials and
we'll talk a little bit more about that
to understand how our body works now and
how we progress into disease and by
understanding that we can utilize the
mechanisms of our own body the machinery
of our own body to drive healing so what
is the biomaterial let's start there
does anybody know what a biomaterial is
yes
that is a perfect example of what about
material is it's a material it can be
synthetic which means it's an artificial
material something outside organic
something we can build in the lab it can
be natural we'll talk about some natural
biomaterials - and those are materials
but the bio aspect is that it's going to
be something that might be implanted
into our bodies it can be something
that's going to experience biological
fluids outside of our bodies so
something that will hold blood for
example or blood plasma or saliva
something that's going to hold these
things so it's essentially anything
that's going to interact any material
that's going to interact with a
biological element which is part of our
our body and so if you're looking at a
picture like this we can think about
these plates agarose plates that are
biometric made of biomaterials
we can think about the scaffold that
this surgeon is using is created of
biomaterials that have to make sure that
we don't make the situation the the
surgery the wound the injury any worse
so we think about biomaterials as
devices or materials that can be
compatible with whatever biological
interface they see all of these are
devices that are made of biomaterials so
how many of you wear contact lenses your
contact lenses are made of a biomaterial
right this is a plastic that allows your
eye to see better functionally but it
also allows exchange of oxygen so oxygen
diffusion across your eye so your eye
doesn't dry out so your eye your the
cells of your eyes and don't die while
you're wearing it they also prevent some
things it prevents biofilm or bacterial
deposition from happening on there so
you don't get a cloudy nasty fungal I so
biomaterials are developed specifically
for a job to do
in response to your body and what your
body needs bandages are another bio bio
device it's made of biomaterials that
they have to stick so they have to stick
to our skin without ripping our skin off
they have to be able to let blood clot
so they have an interaction mechanism
that they have to drive a function in
our physiological systems can you think
of any other bio devices that might be
made of biomaterials that you use
anybody what's one of the first things
that you did this morning to up our
toothbrush is a good one I hope you all
brush this morning is it on you can
everybody hear me isn't it's green yeah
okay sorry about that okay yes so if you
brushed your teeth then you use a bio
device that was made of biomaterials
this morning and that device is cleaning
your teeth but it's also trying to make
sure that you don't have bacteria that
gets infected infected into your gums do
you have a question braces and retainers
are very good examples of materials that
are made specifically for our for our
mouths for Biological interactions yes
a pacemaker is I hope there's not a lot
of you in here with the pacemaker but if
you have a pacemaker yes that in fact is
a device that's made of biomaterials so
yeah so biomaterials even though we
don't appreciate them are everywhere so
did you know that this parachute is the
same device the same material of nylon
that we use for vascular grafts so when
you don't need a pacemaker but need a
vascular and implant into your vessel we
use the same types of materials so the
same kind of polyester that our clothes
are made of can be used as something
that's going to be implanted into our
bodies
what biomaterial is specialists and
tissue engineers do is we take what we
know
about these materials the wood that
you're sitting on the plastic of your
desk we take those and we make them
specific for our biological interactions
they're very exactly vascular grafts are
something that we put into a vein
usually a very large vessel or an artery
if it's already being cloud plotted up
by cholesterol or some kind of a block
then we want to make sure it stays open
and stays clear so we have very good
blood flow and so we put vascular grafts
or stents into them good question
has anybody seen commercials like this
what is what's happening here yes before
and after what's the before issue in
this this picture I bagged yeah yeah I
bags wrinkling skin yeah I'm dealing
with a lot of that lately yes and so
what we've done as engineers and tissue
engineers is develop skin place
replacements or skin topicals
that stretch your skin so that those
wrinkles go away
so biomaterials don't even have to be
something that's going to be very
invasive they can be even something as
as non-invasive as shampoos so this
shampoo is made of the same polymer
system the same materials as this skin
this new skin product but it's for hair
as opposed to being for for skin so
really what our job is is to utilize
systems that are already in development
and already out in the world to help us
look more like Jennifer Aniston or as
close as we can get but to improve our
our health we used these kind of drugs
all the time we use them for pain
medication so how many of you have ever
taken Tylenol okay lots lots of us have
have tripped and fallen and had an
injury well the difference between the
tylenols
are some
things like the release of these these
Palmer these systems how do you think
this happens how do we have the same
drug same name delivered at two
different times
this one is an extended release it's
gonna last in our bodies for a long time
where this one is a rapid release yes
one of them is in liquid form very kind
of yeah but they can both be in liquid
form and and be in the same capsule
that's what one example yes but when
we're thinking about the delivery and
how these get out we can change the
biomaterial base of the capsule in order
to time how we want these to be released
so we can say oh yes
I want this to be an extended release
tablet so I'm going to embed the drug
into a polymer or a biomaterial a
plastic that's going to dissolve very
slowly or I can have it in a capsule
that's going to dissolve very quickly
and give me a burst release so the same
biomaterial but it's modified and all of
these don't have to be plastics polymers
are plastics and that's what we usually
think about when we think about things
that we're going to put into our body
but what were we talking about
biomaterials as a whole
those can be metals those can be
ceramics they can be plastics they can
be natural collagen they can be almost
anything that we can devise as long as
we tailor it for the physiological
response we're trying to build that
we're trying to get back and metals were
amongst the first biomaterials ever used
he even in the BC era so when we first
developed orthopedic transplants were or
in this case an artificial limb they
were heavy steel structures heavy metal
structures do you think that you could
run very fast with a leg like this no
the idea here was not that it was going
to be
very pretty it wasn't going to be very
lightweight but it was going to serve
the function of balance so that this
young woman warrior could get back on
the horse and go fight again but now as
we think about what the function of
these is to be very specialized we've
developed very lightweight titanium
flexible materials that have a very
different function so we're always
innovating these materials even though
we say well we know metals and we know
plastics
we're always innovating them to make
them very much more specific for the for
the job we want them to do and so that
leads us to this idea of tissue
engineering biomaterials is the basis of
tissue engineering what do you know
about tissue engineering anybody have
you ever heard that word before this is
awesome all right well tissue
engineering is the idea that we can
build new tissues with biomaterials so
with that metal leg we weren't building
a whole new leg because we know that the
leg has bone in it it has muscle in it
it has veins in it so it has a lot more
structure that makes it more like a real
leg than just having the function of
balance so tissue engineering is really
the idea that we're developing whole new
tissues whole new organs composite
tissues so that we can replace repair or
regenerate the organs that we already
have so we're trying to make the human
body better after an injury after damage
after disease than it was before
and so tissue engineering really is the
the place where we are thinking about
not substitution of parts with an
artificial structure but replacing the
parts with either a tissue or a whole
organ so when we're talking about an
organ what kind of organs are we talking
about what do you think an organ is
things that have bled she said things
that have blood carry blood things
already that are inside our body lungs
yes a lung is one of the most important
we call them our vital organs right
they're vital to our survival for us to
be able to live back there in nobody
appreciates skin it's one of our most
important and vital organs to protect
our systems from the bugs that are out
in the world from the splinters from
from the tetherballs that hit us it's
it's important ya know all right so yeah
there's so many organs in our body that
if they were damaged we'd love to
recreate them the heart another vital
organ important in our survival so if we
can recreate them and not just repair
them we might be in a better place than
we were before
so as the young lady said one of the
things about tissues and organs is that
we have to have cells live in the space
and they have to be informed by the
biomaterial or their environment the way
I think about this is that cells if
you're looking at these cells right here
they get information from outside
outside the proteins that are outside of
them it's just like us if I go to a
Beyonce concert I'm not gonna fall
asleep I might be twerking I might be
doing a little you know moving left and
right and dancing around right I'm not
going to be just laying down and
relaxing however if I go to a like a
Barry Manilow concert I might fall
asleep I don't know does anybody know
who Barry Manilow is anymore yeah so the
environment the signals that you get
from outside of your body tell you how
to respond and that's the same with
these cells they get signals from
outside of themselves that tell them how
they're responding to their body and
that's what my own materials do so in
our hands when we're tissue engineers
we're telling the cells how they're
supposed to respond and how to react to
their environment
and the major component of our organs
and our tissues that are driving
cellular response if something that's
called the extracellular matrix the
extracellular matrix is just a whole
network of proteins that are woven
together to give signals to cells has
anybody heard of the extracellular
matrix before yes what do you know about
the extracellular matrix the electron
transport so it's involved in electron
transport but its major function is to
give structure mechanics to our tissues
and also those chemical signals that
tell our cells what to do so it's both
bio mechanically relevant mechanics and
biochemically relevant collagen is an
extracellular protein has anybody seen
the influence of collagen yeah yeah so
we've all seen examples of how collagen
a major extracellular matrix protein can
be used in human systems in order to
give us more structure right so here
she's giving herself fuller lips filling
up the tissue mechanically in order to
give herself a duckface I'm not sure
what this look is supposed to be but I'm
more appealing in her mind presentation
so we use these biomaterials and this is
a case of natural materials to enhance
mechanically or biochemically a cell's
response or structures response now with
tissue engineering though what we've
started to do and what the goal is is to
take those extracellular matrix proteins
like collagen embed them into plastics
or metals or ceramics and then take
cells outside of from our bodies either
our own cells the cells of some lineage
that has been preserved and passed and
passed forever for a long time and we
can grow new tissues in that way so that
allows us to grow this new heart
the
new blood vessel the new lung tissues
really helping us to create tissues that
are ultimately going to let those
engineered tissues then be implanted
into or transplanted into patients to
help disease and we're already on the
way so this sounds really science
fictiony to a lot of people for whom
tissue engineering is new but we're
already at the place where we've
developed many of these structures yes
[Music]
that's so that's the that's the key we
are providing the mold so as you would
say a starfish can regrow a limb but
they do that through just regeneration
without signals from an extra an outside
source we're providing the outside
source so that we can give structure to
cells and say oh I need you to grow in
the shape and with the same outcomes as
a lung or I need you to grow in the same
shape or the same mechanics and the same
function as a heart so we direct through
biomaterial structure what we want these
tissues to be that's a great question
yeah so the complexity of it is each
part of a lung for example is very
different but when we're thinking about
this these cells not only are they
responsive to these chemical signals
they also sense mechanics they sense
their environment in both shape and
stiffness and elasticity and so those
signals we call them Meccano
transductive signals are absorbed by the
cells just like when we're sitting in a
plane we know oh I cannot stretch out
and be completely relaxed we know that
we have to sit as small as we possibly
can in order to get the function of our
body is transported by that plane right
our cells are the same thing they know
that both structure and influence from
the signals around them that are
chemical matter to what they're going to
become very good question you guys are
geniuses so here at Yale we've already
developed a number of these tissue
engineered products that are both
inhuman and still experimental so Laura
Nicholson's lab and her company had
developed the first large vessel
transplant from autologous from our own
cells that go into our own bodies so we
didn't think that this was gonna be
possible but about 10 years ago she came
up with the idea and was able to
construct a first large transplanted
vessel and those are in human trials
today what does this look like to
anybody
a brain kind yeah kind of I'll give you
a hint it's kind of hard it looks like a
rock yeah somebody said it bowed yes so
this is a bone structure and it's a
ceramic biomaterial into which bone
cells were seated and they say oh this
is a stiff environment I want to make it
look more like bone I'll deposit calcium
and get mineralized tissue right so our
cells are responding to responding to
the stiffness and to the signals from
the chemistry in the chemistry of these
scaffolds what is this
what kind of organ does this look like a
kidney hmm it's in that area a bladder
nobody ever gets that yes a bladder okay
so a bladder is essentially a membrane
of cells and tissue that expand and
contract and expand and contract when we
needed to and that kind of balloon has
been already generated as a tissue
engineered organ and it's getting ready
for transplant into humans now this is a
complex structure what is this not a
heart lungs yeah so these are
decellularized tissue engineered lung
constructs that came out in this case
from a mouse we removed all of the cells
from those structures and then put new
cells back in them so the environment
helps those cells become new epithelium
new endothelium new lung cells exactly
so that's that's the difficulty in what
we do the difficulty is so far the
reason that this these things don't
survive these complex structures don't
survive is that they're lacking some
very important features so if I told you
we can grow epithelium in the lung we
can grow with can grow nerve cells in
the lung and we can get these to be very
dense tissues
but they died pretty early why would you
think that these tissues these tissue
engineered constructs they have the
signals from their environment they have
the structure but they're dying why
would they die blood vessels blood
vessels are the key so what we've come
to understand about tissue engineered
constructs is that that very thin
balloon that bladder it works really
well because it's a very thin balloon a
thin layer of cells but as we get into
much more complex structures these have
different kinds of structures within the
structure and one of the most important
parts of a tissue or an organ is feeding
it just like us if we don't get fed
we're not going to survive and the way
we feed ourselves and the way we feed
our organs is through vasculature and
most importantly it's not just our large
vessels our veins and our arteries but
our smallest vessels did you know we
have what we call capillaries that are
our small small vessels even smaller
than capillaries we have post
capillaries mid capillaries pre
capillaries all these smaller vessels
that feed into those tiny tiny little
vessels that just one little blood cell
at a time has to line up to go through
did you have a question it's an
irrigation problem exactly
so you see you see where I'm at right
okay so we have to be able to build
micro vessels and post capillary venules
mid capillaries venules into these organ
complex structures in order to keep them
alive and in fact if we go more than
three or four cells deep into a tissue
we can't allow for diffusion of these
particles to happen without a blood
source so if we're talking about a
hundred micron structure we're not going
to get good infusion through the whole
of that structure without some kind of
blood source and so that's really where
my lab and my work take take over we're
really interested in understanding the
extracellular matrix environment those
collagen those proteins the biomaterials
that we can use both mechanically
and biochemically to drive small vessel
growth yes
how do cancer yes so what cancers yes so
cancer cells and other other kind of
cells fibrotic cells they can release
things like vascular endothelial growth
factor and these signals go to the the
vascular cells and say oh let's grow
let's grow in abundance
so if you think about anti tumor
technology a lot of those dampen that
response so that you regress those
tumors so you earth those best
vasculature structures yeah
so really regulation of blood vessels
can be for both good and bad yes that's
a very good question and we're working
where we work on that so the idea and
what I'll show you is some of what we've
done for idiopathic pulmonary fibrosis
patients is really thinking about which
area you will get the first sprouting of
disease how we can recreate those
structures and then investigate drugs
and therapeutics against that yes why
can't we kill cancer oh that's a really
complex complicated question and I swear
I would be a Nobel Prize winner if I if
I could answer that but there because
there's a lot of good cells in that
environment and a lot of bad cells that
are mixed into those environments it's
difficult to target therapeutics right
towards killing only only the bad cells
and I think that's one of the major
factors in differentiating therapies
that are going to be effective for
cancer tumor therapeutics or and and
functional in those in those Coast
states yes
why can't you so there are cancers that
can be taken out of your body so in
those are our tumor to Mars yeah so
targeted cancer therapies are one major
area of research that people are
focusing on so when your immune system
is weakened how do you stop the bad
cells from taking over or viruses or
bacteria from what so it's a concerted
effort and so you end up having
hopefully both therapeutics and an
accumulated immune response that helps
there so I'm gonna go on and we'll stop
for a few more questions in just a
minute
they wanted to get to a couple points so
we use these plastic systems like one in
one case we have a polymer called
polyethylene glycol and we can make
these so that they are specifically
bioactive so we can make these look like
lung proteins or look like vascular
proteins and what that ends up doing is
we can create then a structure that if
this is a human tissue that operates
like a lung tissue a vascular tissue and
but the problem is and when we make
these plastics if you look at a plastic
map Nalgene bottle then you make these
they don't look exactly like a human
tissue so we've developed ways that we
can grow crystal structures and those
crystals we can build the polymer around
them we can then degrade the crystal
and what we're left with is a scaffold
that looks a lot more like human tissue
right so what this does is it gives us
cells the architecture because we can't
just think about the bulk shape we also
have to think about what the cell see in
their little space there are little
bodies they have to see very little
detail and so in doing this not just the
architecture chains but what else do you
think changes as we pull coals in it the
amount of blood cells I can get in there
it might change to look to be look more
or less like human environments but one
of the things that we recognize is that
as we put holes in something it gets
weaker so we can control then the
mechanics because I meant as you know I
saw your skin is a lot more elastic a
lot softer than your bones so if we're
going to make tissues that are very
specific then we need to have something
that is very soft like skin very elastic
and can get very stiff like bone so both
the poor Asian through this architecture
and also the the polymer structure can
give us changes in that McCammon
mechanics that mechanics mean something
to those cells as I mentioned they have
mikado sensing abilities and on a soft
substrate on a soft material they will
look very rounded and as you get stiffer
and stiffer and harder and harder then
they start to spread out so yeah so
these are cells that are now stuck and
these these cells that I'm showing you
our fiberglass yes so we're looking at
mechana responsiveness of the
fibroblasts in this case but if we put
into belial cells onto these structures
what we can see is that they sense their
environment if we put those proteins
into this collagen laminin fibronectin
we can get these very nice networks of
vasculature so we're on the way to
creating vessels that we'll put into
these biomaterial structures to give us
those functional lungs and that
functional liver functional kidneys and
ultimately what we're doing right now is
getting these to grow together so that
we can have not just structure but
perfusion and what you can see here are
cells that are flowing through these
systems so we can get blood flow across
these these vessels exchange of oxygen
factors and nutrients that really feed
the organ which is ultimately how we'll
get a whole tissue a whole skin a whole
lung in order in the place where we can
allow it to be transplanted into a human
and we're doing these with all of these
structures so we're doing it with liver
we're doing it with heart tissue we're
doing it with lung and we're doing it
with skin ultimately the goal again is
to build these artificial tissues that
look so much more like human tissues
because they can be fed
yeah yes yeah so what we do in
three-dimensional structures just like
irrigation we have an inlet we have an
outlet and we can flow blood we can flow
media blood plasma and blood cells
through these so we can actually see
that that they are patent blood vessels
yeah okay so what I hope I've been able
to to convince you another question
so can we put sensors in so we put both
molecular sensors in there so molecules
that will fluoresce under a particular
pressure or particular flow rates but
you can also put electrical sensors into
these scaffold if you if you wanted some
kind of outcome yeah so so far we only
use those in experimental systems to get
an idea of what the for example pressure
in the tissue looks like and we haven't
transplanted those into patients but we
know that there are people who are very
interested in developing artificial
lymph nodes for example that have
electrical signals built in there to
release to tell cells went to escape and
when to come back went to home to those
environments yeah so what I hope so far
to have convinced you is that
biomaterials they're everywhere in our
world and as engineers what we're
supposed to do is we're supposed to make
them work for our bodies we should we're
supposed to make the parachute fit into
our blood vessels and we can do that by
just changing the chemistry and changing
the mechanics of these systems we also
now understand that the smallest of our
blood vessels are those irrigation
systems those are the things that we
need to make sure that we get good blood
vessels into the whole of our tissues in
order for our tissue to survive and to
grow otherwise we have no no hope of
getting these large constructs and these
these bigger structures to get to
survive outside of our bodies or in our
bodies but we're still in experimental
phases of this a lot of what we do is in
animal models in the in the lab so still
very experimental and we're trying to
see how we can use our knowledge of
these tissue of these structures to
advance health much more rapidly and so
we've talked a lot about lung and one of
the problems that it as people get older
or as they get to these states is that
the lung becomes stiff and when disease
specifically called idiopathic pulmonary
fibrosis the lung tissue this is a
healthy lung tissue and this is a
diseased lung tissue the lung tissue
doesn't expand anymore so what kind of
problem do you think is that
you can't breathe your lungs are there
to expand and absorb all the oxygen you
can carry and then compress and let it
out right so if we can't expand and
compress our lungs they don't have the
mechanical elasticity if they're too
stiff and too hard to expand then we're
not going to breathe the way we're
supposed to it probably there's a lot of
reasons a lot because our bodies might
reject an animal's lungs that make it
difficult to do that
so what we're working with is taking
human lungs
these are human lungs taking all of the
cells out of the human lungs and
repopulating them with with with human
cells and so that's probably going to be
the best way for us to start to
reconstruct artificial tissues yeah you
hurry up and get it out of there right
so you tried it there there are
immunosuppressive therapies that people
use during transplant to try to keep
your immune system from rejecting a new
transplanted tissue but if those don't
work then you have to do another surgery
another transplant so our goal here is
because now we understand that mechanics
of the lung is very important and that
belong because very stiff as you get
these disease states is to try to model
this if we can model this by
understanding how soft a healthy lung is
and how stiff a fibrotic lung can be we
can use those biomaterials right we have
biomaterials that range this the
softness of a healthy lung all the way
to the stiffness of a fibrotic lung and
if we do that and we put these lung
tissues in there we can see what the
effects of drugs will be on stopping the
progression of fibrosis
this on reversing fibrosis once it
develops and then people won't need
those lung transplants because lung
transplants are the only way to save the
life of a person with fibrosis at this
point we want soft soft lungs but we
want them to be
we know how soft we want them we don't
want them to be completely mushy they
have to have some kind of structure so
we want to make sure that they can have
the kind of structure that allows for
them to expand without rupture but still
can expand so we have a range does water
so you're protected if you're drinking
water so inhaling water it is dangerous
it's you don't want to do that but
drinking water is is fine so your lungs
can get rid of some some levels of water
if it's completely if you're submerged
that's called drowning and it's how you
you won't survive that yeah yes yeah so
we have diseases in which our lungs get
too too mushy so where again you can't
breathe you can't push air out if you
don't have any mechanical strength so
it's the opposite of fibrosis yes
no we're using um so in this these
experiments um what I'll show you here
is that we can use human primary cells
we repopulate the cells that the tissue
that we develop the lung tissue in this
case and we can look for protein
expression by those cells that tells us
oh these cells are now diseased in
response to that tissue or if we hit
them with a drug a trial drug that we
can say oh the disease is now becoming
inhibited or it's being reversed exactly
exactly yeah so we check ourselves we
take these cells out of human volunteers
and human cadavers and we put those to
test those cells to make sure that they
are doing what they're supposed to in
the environment and then we drive them
again towards disease we hit them with a
drug and see if the drug helps reverse
the disease and in this case of tissue
fibrosis or lung fibrosis we've been
able to fast-track a clinical trials for
this drug in particular because what we
see is that when the tissue got very a
lot of color collagen in there which
prevents the mechanical expansion we
were able to see that this drug was able
to reverse both protein expression the
cells response and also the collagen
what was really good about this is that
we could also see that these drugs got
the stiffness of those lung tissues all
the way back down to something close to
healthy so a tutu tutu so what this
means is this biomaterials aren't just
for creating new organs but creating
organs in the lab that we can use to
test new drugs for diseases that we
don't have cures for yet we're doing
this for skin too so in this case when
we have a skin burn or skin damage we
can develop these biomaterials that have
some of the proteins that are
represented in the amniotic membrane the
amniotic membrane is one tissue one
organ that has a lot of
anti-inflammatory properties
it has a lot of Pro vascular induces
vascular Genesis because we have all
those things during development when
we're getting when we're getting made so
by taking advantage of what we know
about the amniotic membrane putting it
into our tissues we can start to develop
new bandages and when we do studies we
do these studies on the back of mice
we're looking for thickness of the new
skin to form we're looking for the
closure of the winter in the wound and
we're looking for collagen structures
that are not a representative a scar
because the best-case scenario would be
to allow these wounds to close without
scar formation and what we see is in
fact that we do get some very good
structure and when we compare these to
all of the metrics of no therapy or
current therapies we're getting improved
immune responses we're getting less scar
better collagen development than what we
see with other therapies so we're
developing new skin treatments for for
burns and wounds the last innovation
that we've really done now and what
we're really trying to go for is
thinking about stroke so when we think
about stroke one of the major issues in
a stroke is that when the blood vessels
are occluded or when you have the blood
vessels not no longer working then you
get tissue that dies when that tissue
dies the best case scenario would be
regeneration of new brain tissue new
brain tissue has nerves in it
vasculature of course and other cells in
there that we really want to regrow so
what we've done is we've taken the
extracellular matrix from brain put them
into little tiny polymer beads
biomaterial beads and put supes brain
cells neural stem cells vascular cells
and support cells into those beads we
make these beads of various sizes so we
can implant them into brains we put
cells those neural stem cells and a
filial cells and different types of
cells
into these
beads and then we implant them in this
case into a mouse it has a stroke so we
would put these into the mouse that has
a stroke what we're looking for is for
those cells to escape out of those beads
and grow into the region of the brain
that has and that had the stroke so
we're on the way to regenerating new
tissue new neurons and new blood vessels
in the damage stroke tissue so all of
these are ways that we can think about
engineering materials that are already
in our world and are already in our
environments to look so much more like
human structures that we can heal
diseases and improve our therapy art
therapy DEQ's for for better better
treatment yes so if we can so in this
case of tissue engineering one of the
things we're doing is we're taking
cadaver eyes long or so from patients
that that have died if there's nothing
wrong with the tissue we decellularized
it and then we just use that construct
to reseed cells into this these tissues
and that could be with a heart that
could be with the liver the kidney
I need the vital organs that are very
important to us yeah yeah so where we're
at as I mentioned there are companies
and researchers here at Yale who have
already developed some of the really
innovative large vasculature structures
the skin the topical skins those kind of
structures are already ready for us in
hospitals they're undergoing clinical
trials phase 2 and phase 3 clinical
trials now so ready to go when we're
thinking about these bigger questions
and how we can get these whole organs
that are so much more complex that takes
time
because it's not just the it's well I
think the vasculature is the most
important aspect there are other
elements of these tissues that matter -
so it's testing those making sure that
they
in first animal models they go into
larger animals and primates and then
they go into human trials so that takes
a number of years I'd say at least ten
years for those those to happen but
which is why as opposed to just focusing
only on these large organ structures we
start have started to think about how we
can use what we've learned about the
biomaterials and human structures to
treat diseases that we might be able to
do in in five years as opposed to the
1020 years it might take for these other
things yes
yeah very good question yeah okay so the
first question was what happens to the
biomaterial and in this case we use just
like tylenol and degradable biomaterial
that is eliminated by your system so
cells can either metabolize it or it
gets excreted by by your body and in
this case we've used a biomaterial that
has no immunological response so it's a
bio inert material only imbued with the
degradable properties that we put into
the system and so it's just so it just
goes away when we're thinking about in
vitro or ex vivo vascular ization that
happens that can happen very quickly so
we get the formation of new vessels
within 24 and 48 hours if we give it the
appropriate signals it's all about the
mechanics and the chemistry that you
signal to those cells yes what happens
when you have a heart attack to your
body is to the heart it's essentially
part of your heart the the vasculature
can be occluded and so the muscle ceases
and stops stops beating so then you no
longer have the ability to to to pump
blood through your system but with all
of these methods for biomaterials
development what we've been able to do
is I hope address some new therapies for
disease and understand our own bodies
better thank you for your attention
I appreciate
you have a lot of questions for
professor Gonzales we limit it to just a
couple of extra questions we have a lot
we'll do a couple of questions we'll
have our raffle drawing right for the
teachers and the prize that we have
today and then after that I'm sure
professor Gonzales will be happy to stay
around and answer further questions so a
couple of questions from kids I mean not
kids like me so far
when cells are fighting off the disease
and don't know where to go well a lot of
times once ourselves for example if we
have a splinter
once our cells eat up the bacteria or
the parts of the splinter that it needs
to get rid of they themselves die
we're always producing new cells in our
body both immunological cells and our
reservoir and the cells that belong in
our tissues so yes so we so in the
cancer targeting area people have done a
lot to target specific types of cancer
so for example we could build these
beads and we can have little receptors
or like a proteins on the outside that
only cancer cells can see so that's one
way to target cancer cells that are
specific and maybe deliver these
anti-cancerous Venom's
[Applause]
[Music]